buenas tardes si es definitivamente es
un paso hacia adelante ante una eventual
extradición de assange a los eeuu pero
lo cierto es que este es un proceso
largo judicial que incluso puede tardar
años antes de que una decisión
definitiva sea adoptada ya la defensa de
assange ha anunciado que apelará este
fallo lo más pronto posible al
considerar lo que es un grave error
judicial entretanto el fundador de
wikileaks permanecerá preso en la cárcel
de alta seguridad de belmarsh aquí en
londres de donde permanece desde abril
de 2019 cómo mencionabas cuando fue
entregado por las autoridades
ecuatorianas a las autoridades
británicas
también la prometida de assange con
quien tuvo dos hijos cuando permaneciera
en el asilo de la embajada ecuatoriana
ha dicho que cada día que assange
permanece en esta cárcel su salud física
y mental empeoran si assange es
extraditado a los estados unidos podría
enfrentar hasta 17 cargos como lo
mencionaba el espionaje y una pena de
hasta más de 175 años
ahora luisa en respuesta a estos temores
de un posible suicidio en eeuu que ha
ofrecido entonces algunas garantías a
washington cuáles son
ha sido un cambio completo de la
justicia británica en 11 meses dado que
ahora la justicia británica considera
que si esas cuatro garantías que ha
ofrecido los eeuu se cumplen entonces
assange si podría ser extraditado a los
estados unidos estas son assange antes y
después de un juicio no puede permanecer
solitario no será enviado a una cárcel
de máxima seguridad la que tenga peores
condiciones de seguridad y podría ser
transferido a una prisión de australia
para terminar su condena en su país
recordemos que el fundador de wikileaks
es nacido en australia lo cierto y sin
embargo es que si a sánchez está editado
a los eeuu sentaría un precedente bien
complejo para el futuro del periodismo
la libertad de expresión la libertad de
información y así lo han advertido los
medios de comunicación más prestigiosos
del mundo y también las organizaciones
en favor de los periodistas y la
libertad especial